it's a friday edition of pft pm joining
us now the man who is in charge of the
nfl's response to an unprecedented
challenge as the pandemic intersects
with
professional football it's chief medical
officer alan
sills joining us this morning dr seal is
great to see you as always how are you
doing
hey i'm doing great mike thanks for
having me hey it's great to have you one
of the things that i've been kicking
around is i try to
better understand how a pandemic works
and
how a pandemic meshes if at all with
professional sports and we've seen it
play out with different sports over the
past several months
from your perspective i mean you have
spent your life
your professional life focused on brain
health on brain surgery
how hard has it been for you to pivot to
becoming essentially on the fly an
expert in epidemiology
well mike i'm certainly not becoming an
expert in epidemiology but i think
this is something that's been hard for
all of us in the medical world
none of us have experienced anything
like this before in our medical careers
we've obviously seen in various
epidemics but this one is very unique so
i think that's why it's become very much
a team effort
we've had to certainly for me personally
i've had to lean on the expertise and
advice of many different
people who are infectious disease
experts population health experts
epidemiologists
and certainly my colleagues in sports
medicine around the world
with other professional sports leagues
so we've had to collaborate communicate
with each other because
all of us are in uncharted waters here
and the good news is that we can learn
from each other
and i think that's been one of the very
gratifying things about this pandemic is
this hasn't been about what the nfl is
doing or the nba this has been about us
as a medical community
trying to proactively address uh what is
a very novel and emerging virus and so
we've had more communication
collaboration than we probably ever had
before
across all of those leagues and all
those different levels of expertise
which league would you say you've
learned the most from
well it'd be hard to say anyone because
every single person has has been very
instructive i mean i think
again i talk regularly each week with
major league baseball with nba with
national hockey league with major league
soccer but we've also talked with
australian football league
with rugby we've talked with the
bundesliga the english premier league so
i have to say mike every single one of
them has has added something and it's
expanded our thinking and
again we've shared in both directions
what we're doing listening to what
they're doing
and i think that communication will
continue how much has it added to the
challenge for the nfl to successfully
pull off the season
given that places like germany where the
bundesliga plays
england or the premier league plays
those places seem to have
as a society done better getting the
virus
under control getting to the other side
the pandemic not that it's gone
but they've handled it better than we
have as a kind
how much has that complicated the effort
to play football
in this climate well i think it's no
doubt that
the situation in our country is more
challenging as you mentioned some of
those other countries have done a much
better job or
have have had you know fewer cases and
the pandemic is at a different state
and so it does make our job more complex
in america
but again i think each country is unique
each population is unique each sport is
unique as you know they're different
risk levels and they're different things
we can do to mitigate risk
uh among our different sports but but i
think we we all clearly realize we have
a huge challenge on our hands this is
really hard
uh this isn't just hard for us as the
nfl or pro sports this is hard for us as
a country how are we going to try to
navigate our
way through this pandemic and and really
in a sense mike
can we learn to live with this virus
because from what i read and hear and
see and i'm sure you do the same things
i don't expect that this is going to go
away or disappear anytime soon
so it's it's not about waiting for that
day when it disappears we all hope that
day is
is not far off but until it does what
can we do to mitigate risk and try to
establish some sense of normalcy around
our lives but do so in a thoughtful and
safe way
i think that's the question that not
just the nfl is trying to answer or
other sports leagues but that's what
schools and businesses and places of
worship
we all have that very same objective and
that very same challenge
i agree with you completely on that
point that we have to assume
it's going to hang around maybe for
multiple nfl seasons
and you're in a far better position than
i am to understand the issues
to grasp the nuances but the one thing
to me that seems to be
the topic that would most affect
the nfl point of care testing when
point-of-care testing is available
at a sufficiently high accuracy rate
where you can essentially set up a
barrier
into the team facility into the stadium
onto the bus
onto the plane wherever you decide to
have the testing
that gives you a result then and there
positive or negative that you can trust
that seems to be the thing that will
change everything for the nfl am i wrong
in thinking that
well i i would agree and disagree with
part of that and let me explain
absolutely we would all love to have
accurate immediate
uh of the widely available point of care
testing again that's not just something
in the nfl that's across our medical
enterprise is
everyone would like to have a more
accurate more widely available tests so
full stop that will be a step forward
for everyone
but i think we also have to recognize
what the limitations of testing are
testing is not prevention testing is
about containment
so testing doesn't prevent you from
getting the virus in the first place
what prevents you from getting the virus
are things like wearing a mask
physical distancing staying away from
sick people staying home if you're sick
staying away from crowded places
and all of those risk mitigation
strategies are not going to change no
matter what the status of testing is so
testing is important it's certainly
something that's part of a chain but but
i think of all these different links in
the chain and there are many other links
that i think are are equally important
with testing so
love to see point of care tests
available but it's not going to change
that fundamental
need to still do all those other things
that keep people safe because
masks distancing staying home when
you're sick staying away from sick
people those things are about prevention
testing is about containment but as it
currently stands when you've got a
24-hour lag between sample collection
and test result
if you have somebody who had been
negative negative negative
you find out tomorrow that today is the
day he's positive
ideally that is a doughnut hole that the
nfl would love to close
no question would love to close that but
i'd go back again and say
if in that 24-hour period that you
mentioned that individual has stayed
physically distant has worn a mass done
all of those things
then then again there should be a margin
of safety there for the individual
and for the others and that's why we
have to recognize mike in medicine
there's almost no test that's going to
be 100 accurate all the time so even as
these tests get better and better
we still have to realize hey the test
could be wrong it could be a false
negative
so that's why we still have to do all of
those other measures and protect
ourselves no matter what the test
results are telling us
and by all accounts the measures that
have been put in place at the various
teams
are excellent i remember seeing the memo
that was distributed to the teams june 7
with the first
cut of what the protocols would be and
it is detailed it is thorough and it
creates a sense
that the team facilities will be
safe the traveling squad
when you go on the bus the plane to the
hotels it will be safe at the stadium
everyone will be safe but then at some
point football gets played
and that's the juxtaposition that i
struggle with the most
that we can cross every t and dot
every eye and keep everyone apart and
wear masks and be safe
but then it's eleven on eleventh ball
with guys lined up right across from
each other breathing and sweating and
spitting and bleeding
and how do we reconcile all the things
we're doing to keep guys safe
for the 153 hours a week they're not in
a game
and then to keep them safe for the three
hours when they're out there
in that mix of other human beings who
may be positive and we just don't know
it yet
you know i think you framed it exactly
right if we can do everything right in
those 153 hours leading up to the game
then that's gonna make it safer during
that three hour period because we're
hopefully going to arrive at the field
with everyone who's not infected and so
you exactly described it doing it right
all the time leading up to the game is
what helps us get to the game
site with hopefully no infections and
anyone that's participating
and in the same way that's why we'll do
pregame testing again to try to add to
that that knowledge base but
but we've said all along mike you're
right physical distance and football
they don't go together
you can't play football and be
physically disciplined or at least you
can't play it very well in most
positions
so i think you have to to look at how do
we arrive there in an uninfected state
and then certainly we will look at and
learn from what happens on the field as
well i do think there's some things you
can do during that three-hour period how
you construct your benches
what people do when they're off the
field you know minimizing risks at other
times in and around who's in that
environment who's coming through the
bench area those things are all going to
matter
the other thing we have to recognize is
we'll continue to learn from other
sports leagues here as i mentioned we've
talked with for example
australian football with rugby they're
not exact parallels to nfl football but
but there's a lot of face-to-face
contact and in those sports with
unhelmeted players
so we'll take away some learnings from
that and today you know knock on wood
they've not seen on-field transmission
but but i think it's something we have
to continue to be vigilant about
we'll also get a lot of data you've
heard about those chips that we're using
for proximity tracing
and we'll understand a lot more about
the interactions on the field who really
is around who and for what period of
time so
it is clearly a vulnerability and
something we have to continue to address
as aggressively as we can and there's an
avalanche of information out there about
this virus it's impossible to keep up
with it but
one thing that has landed on my radar
screen
and i know that there's a belief in some
leaked circles that this will be true
that on field transmission either in an
open air stadium
or in a dome that has a state of the art
ventilation system
that that is going to be far more
difficult than transmission in a
confined
space indoors how confident are we as of
right now that there will be a
significant difference between
transmission rates
in a building versus transmission rates
on a football field
well mike i think like you said a lot of
experts that i talk to feel like that'll
be the case but the the reality is
we're still learning about that we we
don't have a season of football or any
evening games to
to sort of vet that hypothesis that has
been the experience of these other
sports leagues around the world that i
mentioned that have started up
and again i think the the population
health and epidemiology experts i talked
to they do believe that these open-air
environments as you said either inside
or outside in the ventilation that it
will help
so again i think it's there's a lot
there that that we can be
somewhat reassured by but there's going
to be no substitute for us actually
getting into it gathering the data
looking at it very carefully and then
adjusting i think mike one of the things
we've said throughout is we're going to
have to be flexible and adaptable
because we're going to continue to learn
things not only from our own experience
but from these other leagues
and as we learn those things we'll have
to fine-tune what we're doing
you mentioned all those protocols and we
spent hours and hours and hours
putting those together with a wide
variety of experts
but those protocols will change they'll
grow and they'll develop and they'll get
better
that's kind of the nature of medicine is
we're always learning and improving and
i think that'll be the case here
one other issue as we look for potential
risks that would either bring the virus
to the facility or take the virus
out of the facility if an outbreak
happens is the concept
of players going home every night and i
know that a
full league-wide bubble like the nba and
the nhl are doing is completely
impractical too many teams too many
people
too much time too much expense doesn't
make sense
has any thought been given to the
possibility of hardening the bubble
around the 32 teams i know this would be
a major hardship for the players and
their families and the coaches and their
families
but basically sequestering the team from
the rest of the world staying in a
facility staying in a hotel
matt ryan the falcons quarterback told
us the other day they have town houses
at their facility where they have
individual
bathrooms and changing areas and beds
has there been
any thought been given to the
possibility of having a hard bubble
around the 32 teams
and having the players and the coaches
and everyone else who's essential to the
operation
be there all season long without ever
leaving
well we've certainly talked about and
debated every idea
including that idea and been very try to
be very open-minded and thoughtful about
that and we've looked at
a number of different scenarios and i
think we landed on something that we
feel
combines the margin of safety with the
practicality that you mentioned
but i like to describe what we're doing
is is what we call a virtual football
bubble which means
when guys are at the facility we know
that we've got the protocols we've got
everything in place
we've done a lot of work and together
with the players association around
education what do you do when you leave
the facility and it's our hope that
players coaches and staff because again
this isn't just about players it's about
everybody
that they are going to primarily go home
it's not to say they're never going to
leave their homes but they're
when they do go out they're going to use
the appropriate preventive measures
and do all they can to keep themselves
safe so in a sense it's
it is that bubble concept but it's just
extended out to each individual player's
environment
and again as you point out you have to
rely on each person to make really
important choices about what they do
and trying to mitigate risk for
themselves but i would just point back
mike again to being flexible and
adaptable as we get into the season and
we see what the data shows us
we're going to remain open to all these
different scenarios and seeing what
seems to be the most effective
so you're saying there is a possibility
at some point if there are outbreaks
that
there could be a sequestration of
players and coaches and teams in a hotel
or in a facility
i think all options are on the table
we've said that we are going to continue
to evaluate at every point and do what's
safest for
for everyone involved and so i you know
best way i can answer that is to say all
options remain on the table
and we'll have to deal with each
situation as it comes up and what we
think is the
safest and most awful way last one for
you and i appreciate you giving us so
much time today as it relates to the
current model the virtual bubble as you
explained it
with players going home at the end of
the day how much
of the success or failure of that model
hinges on whether or not schools are
open because the player can do all the
right things
but they have kids that are in school
and they're at school and they get the
virus and bring it home
player gets the virus and brings it to
the facility 24-hour lag between
sample collection and test result the
virus has gotten into the building
yeah it's a great question mike and
again it's something that's still being
studied again not just for an nfl
setting but you know how frequently are
kids vectors and how do they transmit
what do those rates look like
and even within households this is
something that's still somewhat of a
mystery about this virus
you would think that if someone in the
household is infected that 100 of those
close contacts in the household would
get infected and that doesn't seem to
happen
and we don't really understand why why
is it that in some situations everyone
in the house is completely safe and in
other situations they become infected so
so it is a vulnerability i think again
we've done a tremendous amount of
education as has the players association
to players and their families for
example i've been on several zoom calls
just this week with
with organizations where it was players
and families gathered together and we've
talked with
with spouses and and you know household
cohabitants and children about these
issues
and everyone is going to be in this
together in the sense of trying to make
these good choices and do what they can
to mitigate risk so
again it is very much more so than ever
it's not try to say this is a team
effort and every single person in that
team ecosystem is going to have
responsibility to each other person
that's one thing that's been very
encouraging to me as the players return
and the coaches send a message and the
players send the message
the more guys buy into it and their
families buy into it and understand
that everyone needs to be buttoned up
across the board for this to work
hopefully that will happen
hopefully we'll get our 256 regular
season games 13 postseason games
with minimal outbreaks for sales we
appreciate your time today we wish you
all the best as you
embark on a challenge that no nfl chief
medical officer has ever embarked on we
wish you the best with that we hope to
talk to you down the road
hey thanks very much appreciate it best
wishes to you and i'll look forward to
catching up down the road
all right take care all right that was
dr alan sills the nfl's chief medical
officer this is pft pm
i wasn't planning to add anything beyond
our interview with
dr sill 16 minutes decent length but
i wanted to answer some questions today
i know it's been a while since we've
done that and also
there's some news a little friday
afternoon news dumpage from the nfl
we've been waiting and waiting and
waiting
for the league to do something with
antonio brown
you know my feelings on it i have had a
very strong conviction that the league
has
taken full advantage of its ability
under the personal conduct policy to
drag its feet which it's done for 11
months with
three different incidents involving
antonio brown that have not
been resolved well as of today they
are resolved according to nfl media
which
is the nfl two of the three incidents
are
covered by an eight-game suspension that
was levied by the league now
by way of a refresher first incident
an accusation of sexual assault and rape
made in a lawsuit filed last september
second incident a claim made by a woman
regarding a completely separate incident
that antonio brown harassed
her via text message after she went
public to si.com with her concerns
third incident the felony arrest
of antonio brown after an altercation
with a moving truck driver reportedly
because brown didn't want to pay the
bill
for the items that were being delivered
to his home in south florida he has
since pleaded no contest
to felony charges so that's the one that
was most clearly on the t
for punishment because the base fully
and finally resolved nothing further
to be investigated nothing further for
the nfl to do now
according to nfl media again which is
the nfl the eight game suspension covers
the altercation with the moving truck
driver and the allegation made
by the woman who claims she was harassed
by antonio brown
after raising some concerns to si.com
the original incident the one that got
all of this started
that incident still unresolved by the
nfl
and i get the impression based upon the
reporting from
nfl media i.e the nfl the league is
going to wait and see what happens in
the civil lawsuit before
making a decision on whether or not
antonio brown should be disciplined for
that claim now even though it's not a
criminal case
the claim made in this civil lawsuit is
a serious one
sexual assault and rape and if the
league believes
antonio brown raped the woman that's
suing him for sexual assault and rape
he should never play in the nfl again
so when you consider the nfl's had a
chance to interview her
chance to interview him chance to do
whatever other investigation it needs to
do
it doesn't have to wait for the civil
lawsuit to be resolved make a decision
he did it or he didn't do it see i think
the nfl is concerned about the
possibility
that the league would find that he
didn't do it
and then there'd be a verdict in a civil
lawsuit at some point down the road that
he did do it the nfl would look foolish
finding he's blameless but then having a
jury find
that oh by the way we believe he
committed sexual assault and or rape
but in this setting i don't know that
waiting
makes a whole lot of sense when you're
not talking about a criminal case you're
talking about a civil claim
with a low standard it goes one way or
the other it depends upon who the jury
believes
the nfl needs to decide who it believes
the nfl has had the opportunity to speak
to the people involved the nfl has had
an opportunity to come to a conclusion
come to a conclusion put this behind
everyone
he did it or he didn't do it if you
believe him don't suspend him for it
clear him of it move forward if you
don't believe him
then you believe he committed rape then
tell him he can never play in the nfl
again
period the other thing that's embedded
in this
and i assume based upon the way this has
happened
that he won't land on the commissioner
exempt list if he's signed
but the nfl seems to be
acknowledging that the claim of sexual
assault and rape
made in a civil setting is not enough
standing alone to result in antonio
brown being placed on paid leave
because that claim is still out there
now i don't know whether they just don't
want to
focus on that to crystallize and
articulate
exactly what this suspension means if
again the report from nfl media which is
the nfl
is accurate that only two of the three
claims have been resolved
but this doughnut hole is
just strange that you've made the guy
wait for this long that he served a
14-game
unpaid suspension because no team was
going to
sign him and risk having to pay him not
to play because of the belief he would
have been put on the commissioner
exempt list well now we resolve two of
the three claims
the one that's left is the claim for
sexual assault rape
and he's apparently not going to be put
on the commissioner exemplist if he's
signed
unless somebody gets the ultimate
surprise
where they sign antonio brown the league
says all right the eight game suspension
applies and then he can play for you the
eight game suspension comes and goes
he gets ready to play and the league
says well you know what we're going to
put him on the commissioner exempt list
because of the unresolved claim of
sexual assault and rape this is an
unresolved claim of sexual assault and
rape
either resolve it or acknowledge
we can't resolve it and
i don't know what you do if you i see
i really think that this is all driven
by the concern
that if the league were to exonerate him
if the league were to find he didn't
commit sexual assault and or rape and if
the league concluded that i don't know
why he ever
plays if you find he didn't do it
and a civil jury proves you wrong
then you have an even bigger pr mess and
make no mistake about it
this entire mechanism is driven
by pr it's not driven by some
sense of justice and fairness and we're
going to do the right thing and we're
going to supplement the justice system
and we have our own in-house justice
system to deal with
no this entire effort to police the
private lives of players
is about pr it's about having guys
employed who have been accused of doing
horrible things while not at work
and it was supplemented six years ago
with the opportunity to put the players
on paid leave
when the allegations are so
strong that they can't have the guy
around
and you know the league's position on
all of this is that
uh it's not punishment to put a gun on
paid leave which is completely misguided
because players will play football of
course it's punishment to not let
someone play
to just pay their salary it's a cynical
view of how players operate
i just look i'm glad they finally done
something but they still have left a
major question unresolved and who knows
when it will be resolved but apparently
they're not going to put them on the
commissioner exempt list
and now someone can sign him so who's
going to sign the two leading candidates
seem to be the seahawks and the ravens
i continue
the ravens don't really want to sign him
but they don't want to tell him no
because they don't want to give him
reason
to poison his cousin marquis hollywood
brown against
the team for which marquis hollywood
brown
plays so you kind of hold him at arm's
length
you don't say yes you don't say no and
you wait and you hope and you pray
that the seahawks give the guy a job
because
if you tell him no he isn't going to be
happy obviously
sign him and it goes sideways and you
have to cut him he's not going to be
happy
so you know it's just one of those
strange
awkward things for the ravens where i
think they don't want him
just yesterday john harbaugh the coach
of the team said i don't even think he's
available beside now well he was he
always has been
available to be signed the concern was
if you sign him
he lands on the commissioner exempt list
now some clarity
if you sign him he can be with you for
training camp and then when training
camp ends
and the week one preparations begin in
earnest that's when he begins his
eight-game suspension
apparently without fear of being placed
on the commission or exempt list but
with
possibility hovering that if and when
the civil lawsuit is resolved
there will be another punishment
imposed by the league if i were antonio
brown i would do
what should have been done a long time
ago
what should have been done before that
lawsuit was even filed
right the check to settle
the case whatever it takes make that
case go away should have done it before
it was ever filed
should definitely do it now because if
he wants to come back and play in the
nfl
you don't want to have this hanging over
you all right time to answer some of
your questions i know it's been a while
i understand and i finally given in to
the clamoring
from the pft pm posse the official
twitter account that was set up to
speak as the voice of the fans as few as
they may be
of the pfcpm podcast here's the first
question and it relates to
this whole concept of the commissioner
exemplist how and why did the nflpa
allow the commissioner's exempt list to
morph
without fighting it it started as a list
teams placed players on 2009 the eagles
put mike vic there
2013 jeff demps was there while he
pursued the olympics
and then in 2014 it morphed with ray
rush greg hardy
adrian peterson well the nfl pa did push
back against it
the nflpa did fight it the problem is
that the nfl already has the discretion
and the authority to do this and the
nfl's position was and still
is that you can put a player on paid
leave and not
take away any of his money and therefore
it's not punishment and they did fight
it out
and the nflpa lost and the nfl secured
the right
to aggressively apply the personal
conduct policy
in a way that allows them to put players
on paid length period so don't blame the
union on this
this is something the union fought it's
something the nfl has the right to do
and any of these personal conduct policy
issues you know the problem is
the rank and file generally the vast
majority of the players
will never be caught up in the gears of
the personal conduct policy
they don't really benefit from any
enhancements to the rights
of specific players who find themselves
in trouble
with the nfl so what rights are players
going to give up across the board
to advance the rights of a narrow
handful
of players one or two a year at most
that find themselves
at the mercy of the nfl's personal
conduct policy that's the ever
present challenge and the thing i don't
like about the personal conduct policies
i've said time and again
there are no deadlines there is no you
must issue a decision
within x days of doing an investigation
you must complete an investigation
within x days of having
the reason for the investigation land on
your radar screen you must have a
hearing by this you must do this right
there's none of that there's none of
that
and again if you're a player who's
minding his own business who
never anticipates being in trouble with
the league are you going to give up
any of your rights to secure better
treatment
for that small handful of guys who find
themselves in trouble
and for most of the guys who find
themselves in trouble it's easy to look
at them if you're a player and say it's
your own damn fault
if you wouldn't have done x y or z you
wouldn't be in this situation where the
nfl is potentially screwing you
under a personal conduct policy that is
stacked against the rights
of players all right next question pft
pm posse how does the salary cap carry
over impact the formula
that determines the amount of cap space
each team and all teams combined
have to spend cash per year and the
rolling four-year average under the cba
i think it's two separate things
there's a requirement that on a
four-year rolling average i think it's
now
95 of the money must be spent by each
team on a four-year rolling average of
the total cap
and every year there's a set number it's
99
it's 95 it may be higher under the new
cba of the total money that needs to be
spent
under the cap carryover doesn't matter
carryover is a cap device it's not a
cash spending device you still have to
spend a certain amount of cash
even if you're carrying over cap space
that's my general understanding of it
you know there haven't been any teams
that have gotten themselves into any
type of trouble
with failing to spend the minimum amount
but the bottom line is this
i think the number was 89 per team on a
four-year rolling average
with a 95 per year total league
expenditure of cap
dollars under the old cba you know the
cba you could put 11 cents per dollar
into your pocket under the cap every
year as raw profit and never
spend that money and i think they inched
it up a little bit there's been so much
going on lately
i don't remember it off the top of my
head without researching it
but i think those floors came up some
but look i
i think it should be 100 every year i
think teams should be required to spend
the full amount
of the salary cap it should be a floor
and a cap that are the same
amount the idea is we're putting the cap
in place so
teams don't go crazy and spend the
league into oblivion
fine well that should be the minimum
everyone's required to spend that
because the idea is you're protecting
the teams from themselves there should
be an understanding that that's the
amount that will be spent and again
they've done
work to increase those expenditures and
get the money in the hands of the
players of course
this year and next year it's complicated
by the pandemic and i continue to say
watch for teams to choose to cut
expensive veteran players or to squeeze
them to take less
to save dollars this year when they
expect to have significant losses
due to the absence of fans of games and
to maybe have some cap
money that can be carried over to next
year when the cap
is expected be 175 million per team
which is 23.2 million less per team
than this year the best way to deal with
that dropping the salary cap is to find
a way to carry some cap space over and
maybe you bump it back up and you don't
have to take extreme measures next year
to make sure you have all the guys you
want on the team day one
ready to go next question another
question from pftp and policy what's the
latest the 2020 season could
end and what is the latest the 2021
season could start without everything
being thrown out of whack
the nfl hasn't said anything about this
other than
the flexibility has been built in to
have the super bowl in tampa as late as
the final weekend in february
i think they'd like to get it all done
by the end of february
presumably you would have to move the
scouting combine a week or two
to accommodate that and who knows if a
scouting combine can even happen
if the pandemic hasn't improved
dramatically by then the only reason the
combine happened this year is they
slipped it in before the pandemic was
declared
none of the other stuff prior to the
draft occurred there may be no combine
in 2021 until they have point of care
testing
which allows people to find out whether
or not someone
is positive or negative in a reliable
fashion right now not tomorrow but right
now
or until there's a vaccine i think it
becomes impossible
as a practical matter to have a scouting
compound so i don't know maybe they can
i i don't know maybe i i hate the idea
of a march super bowl
but i feel like they're determined to
get the super bowl in
no matter what they're going to complete
the season for the commissioner has
pivoted
from saying we're determined to play a
full season to return to play a complete
season
complete season just me at the end of
the day the confetti is fired and here's
the trophy
1982 with nine regular season games due
to the strike was a complete season
1987 with 15 games due to the strike
three of which played by replacement
players
completed season so they're gonna have a
super bowl
and how do you think they're gonna do
what they have to do to get the super
bowl play
they're not just going to say we'll have
no super bowl this year think of the
money that is lost
by not having 120 million people tune in
simultaneously to watch the super bowl
they'll play a super
bowl and if the union agrees to it i
mean i don't know
i don't know march april i don't know no
one knows
these are all things that fall into the
category of the stuff we're just gonna
have to sit back
and wait and watch for and that's what i
encourage everyone to do
i got no problem with the question being
asked but i think the practical outcome
of all of this is we're just gonna have
to wait and see
we're gonna have to wait and see ideally
they're not gonna wanna delay the start
of the next season and really i think by
the time point of care testing comes
online
the nfl's experience becomes a lot
simpler yes you still have guys infected
if they're doing stupid things when they
go home
or if their kids are in school and
they're bringing the virus home but if
you have
reliable 99 accurate point of care
testing
your chances of outbreaks on your team
your chances of outbreaks
at games go down dramatic
that's when i think the nfl is on the
other
side it's not here yet there was a
belief it would be here by august
september
if it gets here by october november
that seems to be the point where
everything gets easier for the nfl
and i continue to believe that the nfl
should strongly consider
mini bubbles hard bubbles hotel
for all of the players coaches and
essential staff
away from their fans i know it won't be
easy but if you want to increase the
likelihood of getting the games in you
do that and
point-of-care testing is developed at
the high enough level
that that can confidently keep out
anyone who may be positive and shedding
the virus
without that 24-hour doughnut hole where
in theory
a guy can test saturday show up sunday
he's negative for saturday he takes the
test sunday
and he finds out on monday he was
positive on sunday and oh by the way he
happened to play
a three-hour game with teammates and
opponents
and he was in the presence of officials
and coaches etc that's the concern until
we have point of care testing
pftp and posse one more from that
account what impact will the mahomes
contract have on the overall quarterback
market in the next few years i
frankly believe it will have none i
think it's going to be
viewed as the albatross the outlier
the aberration the thing that
other players will look at and say this
just doesn't apply to us
now look players can't have it both ways
if you are the next guy up you can't say
hey i want a four-year extension
worth 45 million dollars per year or
45.5 million per year to get past my
homes
to get to 45 million a year to move the
bar
by 10 million dollars think about that
the high water mark in new money average
for a quarterback contract
went from 35 million to 45 million
in one fell swoop but to get to 45
million
patrick holmes had to agree to a 10 year
extension a 12-year contract
so whether it's dak prescott whether
it's kyler murray
whether it's lamar jackson whether it's
russell wilson
the next time he's up for a new deal
whoever it is
i think that that a good agent is going
to say
don't bring that mahomes structure
around here
and it's going to be interesting to see
what lamar jackson does because he
doesn't have an agent
will the ravens just take them a home's
contract and offer the same thing
to lamar jackson now the 140 million in
injury guarantees may be a little more
meaningful to jackson because
he has a style of play that makes him
more likely to get injured
but tying the guy to the team
and not forcing the team to keep the guy
not guaranteeing the money in full and i
understand the
guarantee mechanisms make it a little
more expensive than it would be
but it isn't a true two-week guarantee
it's a 12-year commitment by the player
and not a 12-year commitment by the team
and i think for other quarterbacks
it's something that you just look at if
you're the agent you say this is just
it doesn't matter it does not matter and
uh
you know we want a four-year extension a
five-year extension
max maybe a three-year extension which
desean watson is trying to get
and and i don't think that other
quarterbacks if they have good agents
are going to have that
mahomes structure and that home's
duration as some sort of a ball and
chain that they have to deal with
all right libras 500 how does the league
maintain competitive balance
if whole swaths of a team are positive
and need two weeks off at least
say half or more of the offensive line
what if the star goes down
how many games can they cancel or
postpone it seems dubious
here's the thing look
the prospect of a star player getting
injured is always there
week one torn acl early day of training
camp torn acl
ruptured achilles tendons something that
knocks the guy out for the year that's
always there as it relates to covet 19
and as it relates to the possibility of
an outbreak i think that's where this
discretion that the commissioner
apparently will have kicks in
peter king has talked about it we
addressed it today on pft live
sean payton who's a member of the
competition committee made reference
earlier in the week to this notion
that there may be games that are
suspended
if for example an entire position group
is wiped out
i just don't know what it's going to
take
to have a standard that is fair
that is consistent and that avoids the
inevitable criticism
that one team was allowed to skip a game
that it surely would have lost
when another team had to go out and play
with a similar circumstance let's say
one team has no offensive linemen who
are healthy where you're allowed to
postpone the game
another team has no defensive linemen
who are healthy well you have to play
what's the reaction of that going to be
and will there be a different standard
if the game is to be played in the
cluster of one o'clock eastern games on
a sunday
versus thursday night
monday night sunday night
will the bar be higher to postpone
a game for which there is no other game
to watch
or will they on fly consider this on the
fly
flex a game into sunday night raven
steelers due to play at one o'clock
bears packers playing at 8 20 on nbc
bears have no healthy offensive the
commissioner exercises his prerogative
to postpone the bears packers game
and instead of having nothing on sunday
night
you just move the game raven steelers
you're playing at 8 20 instead of
one o'clock the fact that fans aren't
going to be at these games
or if they are it's not going to be many
fans that makes it easier
to just move the games around remember
the playoff game between the chiefs and
the steelers a few years ago
there was an ice storm in kansas city i
would just move it tonight
see all of these things that may be
necessitated by the pandemic have
happened
in one form or fashion remember the game
between
the vikings and the eagles due to the
blizzard move from sunday to tuesday
there's all sorts of flexibility the
thing is though that possibility of the
necessity of flexibility will pop up
over and over and over again
we think we don't know i continue to
believe the nfl is hell-bent
on playing all of the week one games and
then regrouping and reassessing
week two remember every game played in
week two is between teams who have their
buys
the same week you could wipe out week
two and move all those games to the bye
weeks or
if there are outbreaks in some cities
you can just postpone a couple of those
games to the bye weeks of the teams
involved
week three week four no divisional games
those weeks could be wiped out they
could be tacked onto the end of the
season
there's a lot of flexibility after week
one so i think that's the plan
play week one and then see what happens
that's the t-shirt slogan
the nfl this year you know every high
school team every college team and most
pro teams i think they do i don't know
they have that t
no pain no gain right let's see what
happens
is the unofficial t-shirt slogan
for football at every level
at least football that intends to go
forward at every level
because the pandemic is ultimately going
to decide
whether or not football is going to work
and let's hope it does
all right hopefully we've dispensed with
this nonsense take
that by raising the concerns we're in
some way
rooting against football what a crock of
crap that is
now we choose not to be willfully blind
and willfully ignorant of things that
make us uncomfortable
we're not going to apply to the
realities of science
the same dynamics that so many of us
apply to political texts
or facts we just don't want to hear that
cut against our beliefs plug your ears
and say i'm not listening
you know that's fine when those facts
don't constitute scientific reality that
we all have to deal with
so hopefully the nfl can get the games
in and do it in a way that's fair
my nose is itchy and do it in a way
that's fair
and do it in a way that gets as many
games played as possible and
if you listen to the allen st allen
sills interview from
earlier in the show the message
all options are on the table don't be
afraid to take that team
and put it in a mini bubble in a hotel
in a facility in a
wherever away from the rest of society
to ensure
that the virus stays out all right next
question
venit virginia why do we need a national
anthem before games to avoid any issues
between player opinions or fans watching
at home
would the nfl ever go without a national
anthem at the start again that came up
three years ago and it's
easy response just get rid of it why do
we do it when did this become
a thing when did pausing
to have
an acknowledgement of the fact that yes
we are in the united states of america
i mean were we confused did we think we
woke up today in bolivia
i i'm not trying to be i guess i am
trying to be sarcastic i'm trying to
prove a point here
when did it become part and parcel of
sports why does it have to be part and
parcel of sports i mean
there is a political component to the
mere fact that you play the national
anthem
before sporting events it doesn't need
to happen
it doesn't have to happen we know where
we live
we don't need to do it just
because there's going to be a contest
between one team and another team that's
going to have a winner
i mean i had a bunch of trials when i
was practicing law
we didn't do the national anthem before
we started a trial
we didn't say the pledge of allegiance
before we started a trial
they don't do the national anthem before
they remove someone's kidney
why did the national anthem
get caught up in this activity
why it's a fair question
and it would go a long way toward
resolving these issues permanently
if we would just accept and agree we
don't need it
we don't need it it's superfluous we
know where we live
there are occasions where it's
appropriate
to play the national anthem it's
appropriate to say the pledge of
allegiance
i don't know is it is it something that
spilled over from the olympics
but the olympics it makes sense you win
a gold medal you're from a certain
country
that's part of the ceremony it's the
ending not the beginning
you won the gold medal you stand on the
podium
they play your national anthem that
makes sense
until the nfl has teams throughout the
world which maybe it will at some point
tying it to a national anthem when all
the teams are american it really does
make no sense
and and is it i feel like you know you
gotta tiptoe on eggshells is it
political to believe that or to suggest
that
that it's unnecessary that maybe it was
political
for someone to begin doing it in the
first place
and that may be the best way to deal
with it is to just not have it
is that anti-american to that or is it
just
pro cavity pro
let's find ways to remove the things
that potentially
divide us let's find a way to unite us
if sports is supposed to unite us and if
all these people
who want us to not ever mention politics
if that's the way they want it
then i don't know maybe the national
anthem doesn't have a place at sporting
events
all right libras 500 why is it even in
matters of life and death the amateur
cynic in our national character the
anti-intellectual gets as much sway
as the people who put the time and
effort and mind into learning a craft is
our own insecurity
i i i just think that
what's going on with the pandemic is an
extension
of what we have become as a people on
all matters of politics
if we don't like a certain fact
if a certain fact does not mesh with our
worldview
or our political opinions we just ignore
it
or we dispute it i remember back during
the lockout in 2011 d smith the
executive director of the nfl pa would
say
we're all entitled to our own opinions
we're not entitled to our own facts
we have developed a sense of entitlement
to our own facts
in the past decade or so driven by
political disagreement but now we are at
a point
where there should be one
set of facts that controls regarding
how you get the virus how you
spread the virus what you should do to
limit the spread what you should do to
protect yourself
what you should do to protect others it
should be
undisputed but
this concept that everything has two
sides
everything doesn't have to have two
sides the sun rising in the east
does not have a second side but you know
again we live in an era where there are
people who think
the earth is flat we live in an era
where the strangest conspiracy theories
take root and people rally around them
and it makes no sense and it's
concerning
it would be nice if we as a people could
sign on
to undisputed
factual information it really is
1984. it really is
this reality where one plus one is four
and if you say it enough times it makes
it's true it makes it true
and it's dangerous and it's scary and
you would think that this pandemic would
be the occasion that would bring people
together how many thousand people have
to die
before the folks who just stubbornly
want to adhere
to their way of thinking even if it is
flat out wrong
how many people have to die before that
happens how many
ironic cases of guys who
say i'm not afraid of no cova and end up
dying from it
before we wake up and realize maybe
there's something to be concerned about
herman cain
do you think that provided the awakening
or the reckoning for any of the
covent truthers out there probably not
see we developed a sense of pride
and ownership of our political views
that has
caused us to to never relent
to never concede we are as wedded to our
political beliefs as we are to our
families
we are not giving it up and we will
never entertain giving it up
and every discussion every interaction
isn't about
processing information and considering
how that new information may affect our
viewpoint
it's about finding the information that
supports our viewpoint
and twisting distorting or flat out
ignoring the information that
contradicts our viewpoint
but our viewpoint is all that matters we
are a nation of people with viewpoints
that is how we identify and even if it
means we engage in ridiculously reckless
behaviors at the behest
of charlatans in politics and or the
media for whom i continue to believe
that we will be a special place in hell
for leading so many people down a
clearly erroneous path
it's just sad and uh
merely saying those things will get
people upset
even though what i just said is the 100
truth
anything it's like it's it's like
i don't know what it's like i'm just
tired
and i think a lot of us are tired and
maybe that's what
some want us to be those who are
committed to truth those who are
committed to accuracy
those who are committed to reality if
you continue to force
feed distortions and untruths
and bastardizations of reality maybe the
people who
get it just eventually just give up i
don't know
next question happy note next question
should i say that one for the end
at all happy teams if the lions won two
games without matthew stafford last year
they draft ninth and 41st instead of 3rd
and 35th if he's healthy
was his injury a long-term win i see
what you're saying i mean this is kind
of indirect tanking
they get better
the draft higher because of stafford's
injury
i look yeah i mean if he's healthy and
if he can still keep playing
and if he plays at a high level and they
can find a way to win games you know
every year with the lions you go into
the season thinking hey maybe this is
the year
and then they sometimes do something
early on that teases you into thinking
maybe it is the year
and then it all falls apart last year it
was that injury to stafford if he stays
healthy
if jeff okuda ends up being a worthwhile
replacement to darius slade
corner if matt patricia you can get
enough guys to buy into the patriot way
hey look in this year there's going to
be that dumb luck that all of the dust
the team that just gets lucky and
doesn't have an outbreak and i don't
know it's going to be a combination of
luck and a combination of a commitment
to doing all the right things but there
are teams they're going to do all the
right things and they're still going to
be unlucky
because this virus can't be seen this
virus is invisible this virus is going
to pop
up wherever it pops up but the teams
that find a way
to combine preparation and luck those
are the teams they're gonna be standing
when it's all said and done
and maybe it will be the lions golden
arch 17 how will the sunday night
football show
look this year will you be on set no
final decisions have been made
about any of this and the one thing that
nbc has done very well number one is
communicate and number two be flexible
i don't know what's gonna happen uh but
whatever we do will be safe for everyone
involved and ultimately it will be an
effective broadcast whether we are in
the same building
or not and really when you see some of
these broadcasts now like the nba
broadcast last night
on tnt where everyone's spread out like
those old scenes from a house with a
giant dinner table and
you've got the husband here and the wife
all the way at the other end of this
giant table it's just
awkward to have people that far apart i
mean
doesn't it make more sense to have
people in different
locations and put them on screen where
it looks like they're closer together
if you're not close enough to interact
what's the point of being in the same
room
so those are all decisions made by
others at nbc i'm ready to do whatever i
need to do
my preference obviously is not to travel
not to have that extra stress
not to jump on a commercial airplane
every week
um and i think that's going to be a
common belief that anyone
who's in the nfl in any capacity
with a team with a network wherever you
want to be where you're going to be all
year long
i'd much rather just go to connecticut
and be there all season then go back and
forth every week that's for damn sure
but
you know whatever it is it is and
hopefully it happens hopefully there'll
be a season for us to cover
and i i've been around nbc long enough
to know that
the production there and the executives
there will be committed to ensuring
that whatever makes its way onto your
screens at home
will be every
point and an appearance standpoint as it
is in any other
year maximum overdrive with the antonio
brown eight game suspension what's the
over under a number of games he plays
for the rest of his career where anybody
signing with the newfound certainty or
will he just be blackballed as he's been
for the last year he was blackballed for
the last year because of the concern
beyond the commissioner exempt list
i think somebody's gonna sign him now i
think he's gonna be the seahawks
i think he's gonna be the seahawks
unless they get josh gordon they'd like
to get josh gordon
remember last year when they signed josh
gordon the report was it was gordon or
was a b
they went with gordon because he was
available well we don't know when gordon
is going to be available
we know a b is going to be available
after the first half of the season so
you sign him
now whether you bring him in now or
whether you wait we'll see
but it's better to get him now because
then he's on your team
if you wait until the suspension's over
there may be a land rush that emerges
then because think of this
what if somebody's top receiver is on
the covet list
after eight weeks what if mike evans
ends up
with a serious injury this year and
antonio brown's available
i guarantee you that even though it's
clear bruce arians who was with antonio
brown for a season in pittsburgh wants
nothing to do with antonio brown
if chris gobert or mike evans go down
for the season tom brady is going to
jump on the table and he's going to yell
and scream i want antonio brown and
he'll get it
i think the only thing that is keeping
the buccaneers from signing antonio
brown right now is the fact
that they have too many good receivers
and it makes it easier
for bruce arians and jason light the gm
of the team to say
we don't need this guy if that changes
at any point i think antonio brown is
going to be
all over another question from
i don't know 40 what do you think abs
chances are of making it back in the nfl
problems seem to have disappeared and
he's a draw yeah i think he'll be back
i think he'll be back i i now that the
nfl has ruled and it's an eight-game
suspension i
i think he'll be back i didn't know 40
with another question i got a theory
the cowboys didn't sign dak because
jerry is going to try to get aaron
rodgers what do you think well
mike mccarthy's the head coach of the
team now and if we put any crude
or credence in tyler dunn's report last
year uh the excellent story that
laid bare some of the friction between
mccarthy and rogers
i don't know that that is the place
for aaron rodgers to go i don't know
what's gonna happen with dak prescott
and cowboys in 2021
i don't know but it's going to cost
37.68 million dollars to apply the
franchise tag to him again
and with 175 million likely in cap space
well that becomes a lot of money to put
in the hands of a quarterback but if you
don't have dak prescott who are you
gonna get
what are you gonna do remember the
cowboys used the highest possible
franchise tag this year
to keep that prescott in place they
believe in him they want him
and unless he gets seriously injured
this year completely falls off i think
they're gonna want him again
paul pj five a great question with all
the defensive tackles opting out do you
think
running will be more prevalent this
season it's an intriguing thought
now i don't know that so many defensive
tackles
are opting out to make
an across the board push for more and
more and more running of the football
but game specific offensive planning
if you're playing a team that is without
its number one choice
as a stuffing defensive tackle you may
see that team
tested more in the running game i i
think so
especially if more and more of these
larger guys who play defensive tackle
choose to opt out golden arch 17 another
question is there any limit to how many
people a team can travel with for away
games i i think that this year there are
going to be specific limits you've got
tier one tier two tier three access
and i remember seeing it i don't have it
in front of me but there were
in the initial protocols that came out
in june who can and can't travel
and i think that it's going to be
trimmed down to the absolute necessity
they don't want one beyond the minimum
they need in order to pull off the game
so yeah there will be a limit
this year i just don't have it in front
of me all happy teams are alike what's
more likely the niners
finish let's place in their division or
the lions win their division
i'd say it's more likely that the lions
win their division
i can't envision the 49ers in last place
in the nfc west although it is the
toughest division in football
i think kyle shanahan will always find a
way to keep that team competitive
i think it's more likely the lions find
a way to the top of the nfc north just
because i think that
the packers for a team that was 13 and
three and
an impact player or two away from a
super bowl to take the step back that
they did that's gonna linger the bears
who knows
the vikings are in this combination
rebuild reload hold it together but also
replace some parts i'm not sure how
that's going to go either but
it's it's a close call all right
i think that's it uh one last thing
we wrote about this earlier today
the officiating the nfl and the nfl
referees association have not yet
decided
on the procedures for officials opting
out
they have agreed that the crews will be
based on geographic connection the goal
will be to have
as many officials as possible drive
to the game site not fly
at the end of the day though whatever
the opt-out procedures are
and when you consider how many players
have already opted out
i won't be surprised if we have
a surprising number of officials opt out
couple of reasons first of all you can
take a one-year break in your
officiating career
and then come back because you're going
to be an official for a long time
secondly a lot of these officials middle
aged or older
they need to be more concerned about the
virus of all the other things you're
already worried about which is primarily
not being trampled on the field
now you got to worry about maybe
catching the virus out there in the fray
as you're traveling from place to place
you have no home games
as an official unless they can find a
way to construct this so
and it's it's impractical to have
a high percentage of the officials just
basically roll to the stadium
are we going to tolerate that too look
we're going to have to tolerate a lot
this year
are we going to tolerate the possibility
of
every time the steelers play at home
they get the same crew
every time the 49ers play at home they
get all the guys who live on the west
coast
are we going to deal with that the same
officials on a regular basis the nfl
likes to spread it around
this year that may go out the window
this year we may have five or six person
crews
this year we may have replacements who
are called up from the college ranks
from the high school ranks it may look
like 2012 in that regard remember how
bad that was
this year we're gonna have to tolerate a
lot
we're gonna have to accept bad calls and
you know what
when a bad call happens and we know it
will the response should be
hey a bad call is better
than no call it's better than no game
that sense that your team got screwed is
preferred
to the reality that your team is sitting
at home doing nothing
while there's no football to watch so
this is going to be a strange strange
year and i think there will be plenty of
officials who opt out
they also have other jobs they're not
going to go without money
this is a sideline for them see if
they're all full time maybe they'd be
less inclined to opt out
but they have other professional
pursuits and this effort by the nfl
to basically you know
make it cheaper to have officials by not
insisting that they be full-time
employees
could sting the nfl when it's time to
figure out what the opt-out procedures
are
and whether or not these officials will
opt out
but i won't be surprised if they do
um it's not like you're going to get
replaced you have rights under the union
you know if you're a player and you take
the year off
you run the risk that your coach is
going to decide will just keep the other
person
i think the nfl referees association
will
ensure that if one of the top
referees says i'm out this year he's
gonna be back next year and the nfl's
gonna want it back next year
that could really screw things up on top
of everything else
i mean think about it we got 1987 1982
and 2012 all jammed together in one
we're focused so much on the players
we haven't really focused on the
officials and there's a chance there's
going to be
fewer officials than what the nfl needs
and they're not going to be the best
officials
and there isn't going to be an end after
three or four weeks like there was
in 2012. this is gonna be the way it is
all
year long but uh whatever it is again
bad football is better than no football
bad officiating
is better than no officiating we
continue to hold out hope that we will
have 17 weeks
of regular season games with few or no
postponements suspensions or
cancellations
that's what we want and please please
don't come around here with this idea
that because we're pointing out the
things that could go wrong
and maybe the things that the nfl should
do better has some sort of a sign that
we don't want football of course we want
football
i've been a fan of the nfl since i was a
little boy you think i don't want
how many more years i have left i'm 55
now for crying out loud
i want every year of football i can get
i want to enjoy it
it's the way to get through those months
that are just kind of dreary and
you know the sky is always kind of gray
and it's getting cold and the days are
getting shorter
and the thing that gets you through it
until the holidays is knowing
that tonight
you've got nfl football watch it is a
great rhythm
to the months of september october
november december and i don't know what
i would do without it
and i don't want to find out and one of
the reasons
that i've been pointing out what's going
on in baseball what's going on in other
sports what's going on here what's going
on there is to make sure that the nfl is
taking this seriously
and doing what it needs to do to ensure
that it will get the games in
i don't want this constant sense week in
and week out day in and day out whether
or not it's going to work but you know
what i have a feeling that's what we're
going to have
that's part of what we got to get used
to this extra
layer of
maybe there's going to be an outbreak
maybe
this team can't play this week maybe the
one o'clock game has to move to eight
o'clock because the eight o'clock game
can't be played
maybe a game that otherwise was going to
be played on thursday
can be played on monday
maybe we gotta move this game to when
the two teams have their bye weeks i
mean
it's it's
uh it's gonna be a strange year but
we're gonna be here
for it every step of the way we
appreciate your time as always
enjoy the weekend pft live returns on
monday profitabletalk.com
no days off around the clock constant
updates with everything that's happening
now
the teams are in camp hopefully the
outbreaks can be kept to a minimum
and will be ready for football september
10 texans at
chiefs and then the first full sunday
and here's hoping
that it works this grand experiment of
the national football league
we're hoping that they can get it done
and uh we hope that you'll be with us
every step of the way have a great
weekend we'll see you on monday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc
sports